one of the most hotly talked about races
in the entire country as we look ahead
to the midterms is the senate race in
pennsylvania and until about a week ago
here's what everyone knew about the
senate race in pennsylvania they knew
that dr oz the guy from the tv doctor
guy was running and he had trump's
endorsement
even though dr oz seems kind of like a
democrat and he's been caught on air
defending abortion and
that seems to have a lot of policy
positions they're pretty decidedly
democrat positions a lot of people
didn't even know he was a republican
then the other candidate was david
mccormick david mccormick ceo of
bridgewater largest hedge fund in the
world uh sort of a moderate republican
type i think he had filed a brief with
the supreme court in defense of gay
marriage during the obergefell case he
had been taking positions that were
pretty pro-china throughout
his career certainly isn't the only
politician to have done that but still
seems more like a centrist moderate type
of republican and so a lot of
conservatives thought well all right
that's it those are my choices
and then over the past week
seemingly out of nowhere
comes kathy barnett and and there have
been polls that have been released in
just the past few days
dr oz big tv star lots of money lots of
backing david mccormick extraordinarily
wealthy hedge fund ceo
and then kathy barnett this woman who
came out of nowhere statistically now
tied with the two biggest guys in the
race so i said all right we got to bring
kathy on the show so that i can talk to
her i haven't haven't heard a whole lot
about her because all the oxygen has
been sucked out of the room by the other
candidates kathy thank you for coming on
the show oh thank you for having me i
love that recap
i want to be fair to the other guys i
mean i don't know dr oz i don't know
david mccormick i have nothing against
them personally but i just sort of felt
as a conservative myself i'm slightly to
the right of attila the hun i just
thought that the conservative voice was
not really being necessarily represented
in this race and you are running a
campaign not merely on the kind of
centrist moderate fiscal issues you're
running a campaign that is focused in
large part on social issues
you know social issues economic issues
foreign affairs issues right i mean
we've been running for 13 months now now
if you're looking at the media i just
crawled from under a rock yesterday but
it's not we've been running a very
consistent race for 13 months we started
out the gate doing 900 miles a week then
we bumped it up to a thousand miles a
week for the past several months we've
been doing 1500 miles a week all across
the commonwealth so the reason why
people here in pennsylvania know me is
because i'm one of the only candidates
who've been in front of them we had
about seven debates mammoth oz and dave
mccormick only showed up to two of them
we've had numerous forums i can only
remember seeing them at two of them um
and so they gotta you know their their
campaign has you know primarily been one
of you know very glossy and expensive
tbs and getting high in high name
endorsements to come into uh the state
whereas mind was focused on the people
and when you spend that much time with
the people you begin to understand what
matters to them most and i have the good
sense to lean into that because what
they are concerned about i too
am concerned about we all feel as though
something has gone fundamentally wrong
with how our nation is being governed
that has been the scent the center of my
message
to the people of pennsylvania is that we
can do better than what we have i
presented myself as a better option and
now people are mad that i have uh you
know that that i've ran an
extraordinarily uh good campaign and
they're mad at it is that what they is
that what you attribute the success to
is it are you gaining a lot of traction
and a ton of momentum right now because
you've been out there hitting the ground
knocking on doors is it because you are
maybe speaking to the issues in a
different way notably on abortion
abortion is the big issue that's come
out this week because of the potential
overrule of roe vs wade you have very
strong pro-life views do you think that
plays some role in it is it some
combination
yeah it's a combination you know we've
been in a statistical tie for first
place for probably over four weeks now
uh again the media is just figuring it
out right you had greg kelly on newsmax
calling me the woman in red and i was
like greg my name is kathy he said oh
honey right so the media refused to say
my name i was on sean hannity for about
seven times prior to between his radio
show and television show prior to
mammoth oz uh uh jumping into the race
and he loved me and would talk about me
even when i wasn't on air with him and
all of a sudden he's doing you know a
part of the i don't know
it's very insidious what is happening
right now and to a lot of americans i
believe it is unnerving that the swamp
does not just consist of democrats
and that some of the people um who are
quote-unquote republicans who decry
uh critical race theory are now
i'm not critical racers sorry cancel
culture are now trying to cancel me yeah
uh we decry critical race theory too and
that's also that's part of it
i don't like critical race theory i've
never talked about defunding the police
i've never evolved on my stance on black
lives matter this is something i i think
it's really important to bring up
because yesterday i noticed a lot of
blue check marks all over social media
were saying this kathy barnett lady she
might be a snake she might be a wolf in
sheep's clothing because she's tweeted
out and posted videos about blm and
defunding the police and so i said okay
whenever blue checks say anything i
automatically am skeptical and so i went
and looked into it
and what was so amazing was
you had used a hashtag blm defund the
police to link to a video
in which you attacked blm in which you
attacked the idea of defunding the
police
yes it's so i mean like these people
think we're stupid i tell you no lie and
it's one of the comments uh
one of my common points is that they
think we're stupid you have this hedge
fund guy who's walking around and faded
blue jeans acting like opie from
puskokey you have uh uh
mammoth oz with an identity crisis he
doesn't know if he's if he's uh america
first or turkey first he doesn't know if
he lives in new jersey or pennsylvania
is he a conservative or is he a liberal
but one thing we do know that our nation
is in crisis right now we don't have
time for these people to figure out who
their true identity is we need someone
if we've learned anything over these
past two years with democrats primarily
jumping down our throats putting their
foot on our businesses and on our
children and on our way of life is that
we need real leadership and that is what
i am offering to the people of
pennsylvania so although mainstream
media didn't get a chance to get it to
get their pound of flesh out of me the
people of pennsylvania have been vetting
me the entire time and they can't stand
the thought that the people are going to
choose their leadership and not them
well now since the media have not given
you a whole lot of attention until now
you've sort of forced the issue by
consistently doing well in the polls uh
who are you who are you know the
biography that we have is kathy barnett
is a veteran a uh former adjunct
professor of corporate finance
conservative political commentator i've
followed you a bit you know just uh in
recent months on social media and if you
make an appearance on tv or radio so you
know i think people might have
familiarity with you that way but who
are you if kathy barnett is going to be
the next senator from pennsylvania what
are the people getting
yeah listen i grew up on a pig farm in
southern alabama i grew up in a home
with no insulation no running water an
outhouse and a back and a well on the
side when i say poor we couldn't afford
the other oh we were just po
but my family loved me i felt loved and
i saw them working very hard i saw them
waking up early going to bed late
i get emotional when i think about it
because they never called me a victim i
don't remember one time and now as a
black woman married to a black man
raising black children i can't help but
to compare and contrast the culture in
which my children are growing up in
today versus the one in which i grew up
in if my family wanted to decry
victimhood they had ample reason to do
so and yet i don't remember one time
anyone ever looking at me and saying
kathy you're black you're a woman you're
poor all the odds are against you and
because they never gave me a victim
mentality i became the first in my
family to go and finish college i spent
10 years in the military
i was accepted into officer candidacy
school i worked in the financial
industry corporate america an adjunct
professor of corporate finance i
authored my first book homeschooled my
kids political commentator a lot of
different journeys in life and now i'm
running for u.s senate and not just
running but crushing it right because
only in america do you hear my story
this is the greatest country that has
ever existed but the country that
allowed me to be able to claw my way
from underneath the rock i believe is
about to come to a close these people
are very serious we have two people that
the influencers with some of the
influencers within our party have
decided
they should run they're both globalists
they both have very strong ties to the
world economic forum i'm talking about
mammoth oz and dave mccarmey uh
mammoth uh dave mccormack uh he he
invests portions of the sovereign wealth
fund of the communist party of china you
don't get that kind of access to china
and their markets and their money
without also selling yourself out to the
one china way i don't think you can be
in bed with china financially and not
also in bed with china ideologically and
yet he says my experience is going to
make me tough on china although we
haven't seen any of that toughness to
date we've seen him profit tremendously
from his relationships with china and
now we have mammoth oz who says he's a
conservative but when he had a large
platform i don't remember one time ever
watching a show
that that that brought forward
conservative values in fact i always saw
the opposite but now don't let your eyes
your lion eyes fool you he would tell us
i'm a conservative and so i believe what
they're mad about it that the people
once again it's like 2016 being played
all over again is that how dare we think
we get to choose who's going to be our
elected official but i'm excited i am
i'm so encouraged with all the support
and the people who are standing up for
me it is all lies i have not evolved and
i won't now so let's say that the
description you've given is is a fair
one and david and this is my read on the
situation too is david mccormick is a
kind of business republican he's the you
know the really focused on just kind of
economic matters and that's that's the
at least the first part of his message
and then dr oz
i don't know i don't know what dr
the democrat seems like he was for a lot
of his life and he's recently gone on tv
just decrying pro-life laws or radio
rather decrying pro-life laws so i don't
know he seems you know further left and
so let's say that you're the you're the
real conservative in the race well the
old buckley rule is you got to vote for
the most right-wing viable candidate so
what do you make of the criticism that
uh okay
kathy barnett i might agree with her 100
she might be the most rock-ribbed
conservative but you know she's just not
going to win the general
yeah and you know i mean and you know
there's a lot of people walking around
with a crystal ball
who think they can predict the future
they didn't predict me
they
they're not on a good track record right
now listen you can go to my facebook
page right we've been very upfront about
it not only uh do i have a very strong
grasp on the um on the republican base
here in pennsylvania but unlike all the
other candidates you will see me in a
room full of
black men uh changing their voter
registration from democrat to republican
you'll see me in philadelphia and
chinatown um they i have their vote you
will see me uh being ushered into a room
into a room full of amish people who
came out very strong for donald trump in
2016 and you will hear them say listen
to her she has our values i am the only
person in this race who has the ability
to walk into every nook and cranny of
this commonwealth and go and earn those
votes i believe we have the better story
to tell in the republican party i
believe we have the better story i just
believe we keep picking people who suck
at telling it and many of the insiders
influencers within our party would tell
us oh no no steve we need to get a
squishy republican and the people are
saying how has that worked for us
i don't think it's worked very well for
us to send you know warm bodies with an
r next to their name to washington dc
and expect them to to stand up for our
values who are we if now we're going to
let somebody come in who his entire
career he's been talking uh pro abortion
and now all of a sudden uh just because
he can he's now ardently pro-life
i mean who are we do we really believe
that we should have a secure border and
yet we're going to go back to mammoth oz
whose family business was hit with a 95
million dollar immigration fine because
of a scheme not just one or two illegals
into the country but 95 million dollars
worth of a fine right the largest fine
but now we don't care about that anymore
i believe when you're looking at the
people i've always tried to make
distinction between the people within
the republican party and those who would
be in the the influencer within the
republican party the people
who are who are going to go to the polls
on uh tuesday and we're going to vote
for me
uh they believe that it means something
to say that you are a conservative
republican uh but then you have some uh
within the influencer group uh i think
they are less concerned about winning
and more concerned about keeping power
so let's say that you win i i think your
your reaction to this is totally right
which is all these people making the
predictions they never predicted me so i
maybe put the crystal balls away for a
second let's say that you win the
nomination right now you're in a
statistical tie so even if you're a
point behind
one guy or a point ahead of another guy
you know the momentum would appear to be
with you right now let's say you win the
primary you go to washington dc
day one you're in office what's the
program
you can go to my website at barnett for
senate dot com i just put out a couple
of weeks ago my on day one agenda is the
top 10 things uh number six i talk about
ethics and transparency i think we lack
that tremendously i believe that that is
probably the reason why we have such bad
actors um in washington dc the reason
why is such a swamp right people go in
like popers and within two years they're
multi-millionaires right and so my
husband and i have committed to only
holding and investing and
not holding and investing in individual
stocks we will only invest in mutual
funds that reflects the majority of
americans and if we if you remember a
couple of weeks or maybe about a month
ago nancy pelosi cashed in on a 35
million dollar google stock that rolls
up under one of her committees that's
called insider trading um and that's a
problem and when they asked her about it
she said oh capitalism really socialist
so you know um so there are a number of
things but when people say pick one
issue
in our nation it's like trying to drink
from a fire hydrant everything seems to
be on fire we all know it whether it's
foreign affairs whether it's
disinflation
which is as a direct result primarily of
the federal reserve the federal reserve
is broken and it has done so much to um
to to push this inflation is not
transitory it's not going anywhere
anytime soon it is here for um for a
period of time and it's going to hurt a
lot of people i still have family on
that pig farm in alabama although the
farm is no longer operable families
still live there and times are tough and
it's going to get tougher and i think
that those are the issues that people
want to see us talk about in a
substantive way
you can't take someone who's been a part
of the world economic forum most people
know what that is
some people um and these esg scores that
uh that uh
mccormick talks glowingly about i've
heard him at least two times talk about
the esg and how great they are and all
of that it is the complete opposite um
of that for those who don't know the the
esg refers to the uh environmental
social and governance issues it's it's
just basically way a way that investment
firms can push a woke agenda onto the
companies that they're investing in it's
a it's a really really big problem i
have you know i haven't paid very much
attention to david mccormick or dr oz
for that matter so if you know either of
those guys if you want to come on and
refute what uh what kathy is saying you
know you're more than welcome to come on
but as you're saying it kathy yes i mean
if if someone's pushing esg
that's a big problem he absolutely has
and my team and i we've already uh we
put out there on social media um you
know some of this uh some of the um the
statements that have been made with his
firm uh with him as ceo of that firm
cree uh creating a division within the
world economic forum to combat systemic
racism and i think it's very interesting
that his team is now just cutting and
slicing pieces of long-form
discussions that i was having um across
social media and trying to make it seem
like i'm calling the nation systemically
racist i have not evolved on anything so
keep your head on a swivel people in
pennsylvania do not allow them to remove
your
one and only chance of actually getting
someone in office who actually help you
vote uh who will be your voice no i'll
tell you kathy i'm so glad you mentioned
that about the videos because it was the
same thing yesterday when people were
posting your tweets and insinuating that
you were saying the opposite of what you
really said i saw someone posted this
kind of oddly edited video and said it's
this is the real kathy barnett and i
said okay well let me you know i don't
know a lot about this woman let me see
and it was all these little clips it
would say you know uh
white i'm paraphrasing i'm not saying
this directly
white people have privilege
and
black people are oppressed in an end and
be all these kind of little clip things
and i said that why does it clipped that
way and then i i looked for the fuller
videos and it was just like the tweet in
the fuller videos it was you
arguing against those positions you'd
say the leftists are saying
that white people have privilege and
i disagree with it and i just thought
this is so dishonest this kind of attack
that's coming on kathy barnett right now
and it had kind of the opposite effect
of what i think it was intended to do
which is it you know previously i i
don't live in pennsylvania i don't have
a whole lot of opinion in the race uh
but i thought wait if if the attacks on
kathy barnett are this dishonest
this woman must be pretty good
i would agree with that
all right kathy uh one more time where
can people find you
barnett for senate dot com
all right wonderful kathy thank you so
much on for coming on the show i really
appreciate it
thank you michael
[Music]
[Music]
you